Actually I sleep here under this table.
(contemporary music)
(air whooshing)
Greetings all you high vibration,
earth dwelling humanoids.
Those in search of truth, virtue,
and the better world of our collective imagination,
may this invisible wave formation
of ones and zeroes reach your brain,
and find you well, amidst the tumbled of a world
that can feel at times out of control.
May it bring you comfort,
especially to those that are lonely out there,
and grace to those in need of it.
My name is Rich Roll, here again in physical parallel,
in neurological simpatico and verbal symbiosis,
with my endearing instigation,
confederate on all things Roll On,
the honorable and high principled snorkel mask,
adorning Barron of the literary manor himself.
My Liege, my Lord, the humble nobleman himself,
Mr. Adam Skolnick.
(laughs)
A lot of pressure on these intros,
after the response last time, so I had to double it down.
I kneel before you, sir.
Yes.
How may I be of service?
No.
I am in service to you today, my friend.
All right.
For those new, Roll On is typically our opportunity
to shift focus away from our traditional fare
of Evergreen conversations,
to instead hone in on matters
of more contemporaneous time sensitive interests.
Today we do just that, but we're gonna do it with a twist,
after a little bit of housekeeping
and typical opening shenanigans.
We're gonna spend the gravamen of this episode
grappling with recent events in Afghanistan,
less from a political perspective,
and more from a human rights perspective,
with a specific focus on the very grave plight
faced by the 16 plus million women in Afghanistan,
in the wake of the United States' departure,
and the grip of Taliban rule.
It's a conversation and exploration that is aided,
soon to be aided by two special guests today,
Drs. Ayesha and Dean Sherzai.
You know that Sherzai as the neurology duo,
the experts on brain health Alzheimer's
and neurodegenerative disease.
They've twice graced this show in the past,
but what you might not know or remember, is that
they both have considerable experience with Afghanistan,
having lived and worked there for three years,
I believe, beginning back in around 2003,
a period in which Dean was actually appointed
by President Karzai as the Deputy Minister of Health,
and together they created the most successful
post-conflict healthcare system
with women's empowerment at its core.
Lots to come on that,
it's proving to be a fascinating conversation,
but before team Sherzai joins us, Adam, how goes you?
I am grateful. I am-
Are you ordering food at Cafe Gratitude?
(laughs)
No, but I feel good-
That's what they say, they-
I know.
(laughs)
You don't just order the menu item, you have to say,
"I am-"
I know. I am honored-
Compassionate.
I am perturbed.
Joyous.
If I was the manager at Cafe Gratitude,
which I applied for that, by the way.
You did?
I didn't get it.
That's why you ended up at Ben and Jerry's?
So I'm at Cinnabon now.
(laughs)
Off from Ben and Jerry's?
Yeah.
Ben and Jerry's because...
You guys, I didn't work there, I never worked there.
So I applied to Gratitude and Cinnabon, but Gratitude,
I think I would add an I am perturbed item.
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't know what it would be,
but there'd be lots of garlic and onion.
Yeah.
(laughs)
Something like Jewish guilt, effective, put into the menu.
Ideal pickle.
Right.
I'm grateful 'cause, first of all, the scheduling,
thank you for allowing me to be here with the-
Yes, so we're recording this a week early,
because you're gonna be up swimming-
That's it.
And also grateful we're dispensing
with first-world problems here, to talk about
some real life and death issues in Afghanistan.
So that makes me feel grateful.
That's one of the reasons I've always been attracted
to human rights reporting in general,
because it does give you as someone engaging in that space,
the gravity to see the world in the way it really is,
and to be grateful for what you have.
And so there's that element of it there.
Except I did have one first-world problem to ask you,
what's the vegan way of getting rid of a spider
that has taken up residence in your rear view mirror?
Well, leave him be.
(laughs)
Let him live there?
Yeah. Is he bothering you?
Well-
Or consciously relocate him.
(laughs)
Are we sure it's him?
Maybe not. Her.
Yeah.
So no water in there?
Just to like...
'Cause every morning there's this huge messy web.
It's not like Charlotte,
I'm not getting a message in the morning,
it's this mass of stringy web, that I knock down,
and then every morning it's there again.
And today on the drive here,
it blew out 'cause on the freeway, but it'll be there.
Well, and you're dealing with the symptom
and not the cause.
If you're just destroying the web,
but not finding the spider,
and appropriately relocating him to a habitable environment,
I don't know.
All right.
Well, let's do a pod on that one time.
That deserves a full hour.
We need a full hour on this.
I once had rats living under the hood of my car,
so something about my car is an ecosystem.
Mm.
Yes.
A Subaru ecosystem.
All right, well keep us posted.
Next week there'll be an update, I'm sure.
How are you, man?
I'm good.
I've been back in the pool.
I'm feeling grateful myself,
to be wet again after quite a respite.
So that's been really nice,
and it's actually helping my sleep,
and I'm seeing the gains pretty quickly,
so I'm happy about that.
I'm rocking new glasses.
Great looking glasses.
Roca sent me...
They have a fall line, they sent me three pairs of glasses
with my prescription in them,
so I'll rotate those through, but-
Got a haircut?
To get a little bit of a haircut.
It looks good.
Yeah, everything's good.
I love seeing the swim flop.
I think I speak for everyone out there,
when the flop comes down,
then you throw what you've been doing out there-
I dropped the kickboard with all my gear on the deck.
It makes a loud flap on Instagram stories,
every time I do a swim.
People seem to enjoy that for some reason.
And the swims are impressive, man.
You're doing 5K in like an hour or 10.
That's all relative, trust me.
I have a long way to go to get back to form,
but I'm excited to be back in it.
And yeah, people love the flap, and then they...
I love it when people tag me,
they do their own version of that.
And then I always reply with a grade.
There's a very specific way to do it correctly,
most people fall short of that.
So do your swap, tag me, I'll grade it.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
I'm gonna start flapping at the beach.
Yeah.
Well, that would require you go into a swimming pool,
and not the ocean.
Can't I flap on the sand?
That's not the same.
It's not the same thing.
I'm gonna go...
I have to take you to the pool,
and I have to evaluate your technique.
It's not gonna be-
My spidey sense from the spider in your rear view mirror
is telling me that maybe you need a tutorial.
I definitely do.
But you said you were just gonna swear off cycling,
and you did this massive ride yesterday too.
No.
I said, "I need to take a break from running,
and I need to be judicious about my cycling."
So I've dialed the cycling back,
but I'm gonna ride one or two times a week,
and really focus on the swimming.
It seems like that was a monster too.
So it's actually already,
and I'm doing some strength training,
so I'm really dedicated to resolving this back issue.
That's my commitment right now.
Right on.
I do wanna report back on something
that was a big controversial last time we spoke,
which is the appropriate definition of "biweekly."
We had a bit of a kerfuffle last time,
around what that actually means.
Some confusion.
I'm proud to announce that my instinct was correct, Adam.
It was.
Per Merriam Webster, bi-weekly is defined as
something that occurs every two weeks or twice per week.
That's confusing.
How is that possible?
Because even Mariam doesn't know what it means.
Right.
It means both or either?
Yes.
This is sewing mass confusion.
I blame gen Z.
Similarly...
No, it's always been the case.
Similarly, bi-monthly is defined as
something that occurs every other month, or...
No, every other month or twice a month.
This is not good.
So if you say we're gonna meet bi-monthly,
or we're gonna meet bi-weekly...
Right.
How are you supposed to know what that means?
If you like join a new organization,
and then the organization says, "Okay, great to be here.
We're gonna be here by bi-weekly."
And then you don't come for two weeks,
and you've missed three meetings.
(laughter)
Or at least two meetings.
That's not good.
No.
You're on the outs, buddy.
So, with this, hence forth
I despair over the pitfalls of the English language.
I mean, come on, words term, they have one job.
One job.
And this means two different things,
I don't know what to tell you.
Let's create a new word for it.
What's that?
For every other week.
You blanked out.
Too much pressure.
Yeah, I know.
Thank you for coming to my Ted Talk.
Sorry.
This concludes that-
I'll come up with one by the end of the episode.
One thing I wanna mention real quick here,
to shift gears a little bit.
Many of you know and love Josh Lajaunie.
He's been on the podcast a number of times,
his story of dropping 250 pounds, I believe,
to become an ultra-runner living down in Southern Louisiana,
it's a legendary tale.
He's a beautiful human being.
He's an audience favorite, and...
He was one of my favorites.
Yeah, he's incredible guy.
Beautiful, lovely guy.
And right now, he really needs our help.
Josh, his family,
his community has been utterly devastated by Hurricane Ida.
And as some of you may remember,
Josh owns and runs a trailer park.
This is his vocation, and at least 20 family's homes
were destroyed by the recent storm,
and he's been going out of pocket,
doing daily runs for gas, water, ice, food for his tenants,
spending all kinds of cash on tarps
that will serve as temporary roofs until repairs can begin.
He's quite overwhelmed,
and I just wanted to alert everybody to this fact.
Our mutual friend, Howard Jacobson,
who was also an early guest on the podcast,
made a video, I'll link that up in the show notes.
And in that video, he speaks to Josh,
and includes links and a QR code for people to donate.
And I should say, it's not a registered charity,
there's no tax deductions here.
It's just basically an opportunity to send
a little bit of extra cash to Josh via Venmo or Cash app
to help him out, his family out and his community out.
At the same time,
Howard and I've been going back and forth.
He's working on possibly putting together a webinar
with plant-based athletes, that would be free to the public,
but would invite people to send money to Josh,
for him to orchestrate survival
and rebuilding efforts for his community.
I don't have any details on that yet,
but as that comes into fruition,
I'll be sure to let you know.
As I mentioned at the outset,
we're recording this on September 6th,
and this podcast doesn't go up until the 16th.
So in the interim, perhaps this will come together,
and I'll share that out on social media.
Heavy and thoughts with you, Josh.
Right.
And I think that's it.
Should we take a break and pivot?
Let's do it.
Anything else you wanna say?
How are you feeling about Alcatraz?
I feel great about Alcatraz.
Did a good swim,
our friend Neil Strauss joined with Kyle Thiermann,
who's a friend of mine.
I know Kyle, he's been on the podcast also.
Okay, perfect.
So Kyle, the veteran of Mavericks,
big wave surfer, podcaster.
Now he works at Mud/Wtr, he's a writer and editor there.
I didn't know that.
And so he was out, another friend of theirs, Chris,
came my buddy, John Moore, who you've met,
my swim buddy, who I'm gonna do Alcatraz with was there.
And we all got in the water,
it was fun, at (indistinct) Rogers,
no sharks reported.
Reported, that's the key word.
No sharks reported.
Did you have the Malibu artist in tow though
to verify that?
He was there.
But I felt good.
It was one of those funny things.
I don't know if you've ever had this, but my watch,
I have the Garmin Descent,
which has a free dive application.
And for the first 1300 yards, it's working perfectly,
and I was in a good pace for me.
And then on my swim back,
I'm waiting around for John and some others,
and I couldn't find them.
So I started swimming back,
and then it just stays in that same yardage,
for like 30 more minutes.
And it didn't until I was getting out
after the whole swim start taking over.
Which is, it's only funny that I never cared about
how many yards I was swimming,
or the time, it never was even part of my life.
But as soon as you have that watch on,
and you're starting to measure your workouts,
it's so annoying to not get it.
Well, first of all,
why do you have it on the free diving setting,
when you should be on the open water setting.
It's on the open water setting.
Yeah, you said it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
These things are not perfect.
Tech doesn't work.
(laughs)
All right.
Well, we're gonna pivot to things that do work,
or hopefully things that can be fixed.
So we're gonna take a quick break,
and we'll be back with Ayesha & Dean Sherzai.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snack a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is,
most people I know actually already know how to eat better,
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plantpower Meal Planner, are affordable, all-in-one,
digital platform that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership,
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people, for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code,
RRHEALTH, for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
And we're back.
We're joined by Drs. Ayesha & Dean Sherzai,
along with Mr. Adam Skolnick.
Good to see you guys again, thank you for doing this today.
Thank you so much for having us.
Yeah, I wish it was under better circumstances,
but I feel like the conversation
we're about to have is an important one.
To help us all better understand
what's happening in Afghanistan, how we got there,
and perhaps some solutions for all of us
to avail ourselves to participate
in ameliorating the hardship that's going on there.
But before we even get into any of that,
I think it would be instructive for each of you
to recap your relationship with Afghanistan,
and your experience there.
Sure.
So I was actually born there.
My parents and my grandparents are from Afghanistan,
were from Afghanistan.
And when I was a medical student,
I had an opportunity to go back and help out.
I think all of us grew up
with this idea to give back to the community.
That was something that was instilled in us
by our grandparents and our parents.
And back in 2002, I went back there to help out.
I was with Doctors Without Borders,
and with some other phenomenal individuals.
This was the post Hollomon era.
And I was very passionate about helping women and children,
as was everybody else.
And it was one of the most beautiful times of my life,
because there was a rebirth of hope, where
after a very prolonged period of darkness and hopelessness,
suddenly an opportunity became available
for men and women, but especially for women
to find freedom, to find their voice, to educate themselves,
to interact with each other,
and to be really accepted as human beings,
in a society which shrouded them,
which just deleted them from the face of this earth.
And so to have been in that environment,
where you saw this growth, this hope,
and the continuation of that hope over many, many years,
and now to see this devastating effect
of taking away that hope from them overnight,
is just catastrophic.
So even though Dean and I
are in the field of neurology and brain health,
and we talk about everything brain health,
I think it's very, very important for us
to talk about something that is powerful,
that not just is a calamity
that has affected a particular population,
I think it affects all of us as human beings,
because it's an overnight extinction
of 16 million plus human beings on this earth,
these women who were given hope, and it's worse than that.
You're taking away that hope from them.
Yeah.
Dean, I wanna hear your experience as well,
but Ayesha, this was...
So when you returned to Afghanistan, it was around 2003?
Yes.
So we're talking post 9/11,
it was that era of optimism and a sense of possibility,
where rights were being restored,
and everything seemed to be moving
in an upward positive trajectory,
at least with respect to human rights.
Yes. Absolutely.
When people watch the news or watch clips from Afghanistan,
and how the west and the United States went there
to help rebuild the country and provide security,
they don't realize that the biggest asset
was providing opportunities for women,
for this population that never had that opportunity.
And for them to become
very successful models of progress in a society.
I mean, just imagine half of the society
not being involved in making decisions for the country,
suddenly all of them came into forefront.
And it was this beautiful
regeneration of a culture and a society,
where music was brought back, where art came back.
And when you provide that security, creativity is born.
And so we saw the manifestation of that security.
The very thing that makes me so sad
is that it's just not there anymore.
Yeah.
Can I ask?
Just to set the context for listeners who might not know,
when the Taliban came in in the mid to late nineties
and ruled there, music was like...
You couldn't play recorded music,
photographs were outlawed,
certain books were outlawed, film entertainment,
that was outlawed by punishment of death.
Right?
Is that correct?
Like recording tape
would be hung from the trees as a warning.
Yeah.
So then you're saying, this openness brings it all back?
Absolutely.
It's difficult to perceive that limited way of life,
where anything that almost brings pleasure
is completely negated.
And so in the absence of that freedom,
it's not just helping
a particular set of population live a normal life,
you're basically killing progress in many ways.
And Dean and I actually saw this metamorphosis
that was happening early in the early 2000s,
when we were working there together.
We actually met there during that time,
and we got married there, we dated there.
One of the most amazing experiences.
And you were talking about
what was during the Taliban in the nineties,
and what happened.
I was there right after the 9/11, end of 2001,
I was at NIH doing these wonky research in building 10,
where you put probes into the basal ganglia,
and all this stuff.
And because of my background in management,
they asked me to go back to Afghanistan
to see if for three months, if you can help out.
And I went back, it was supposed to be three months,
I'm not gonna give up that career.
And the first day I go there...
And by the way,
at the time I'm living on a lake in Reston, Virginia.
And I land into the airport, this is at the beginning.
There's no light, there are no lights,
there's no electricity.
People are just walking around
almost like a zombie esque, no color.
The first thing I do is drive through the city,
and there's no building standing in this one street,
that's famous street, third street.
And no building.
And you see these little heads popping up,
and you look around like, "Oh my gosh, why...
Shouldn't they be told not to play there?"
"Oh, no, that's where they live."
So it was the emotional,
the visceral nature was just so great.
Three months turned into three years,
where the president asked me
to stay and rebuild the healthcare system.
But what I saw was...
And this is critical, because I think this is important
for all of us as human beings.
I think what the most important part of this conversation
that you're bringing, and similar kind of conversation is,
for people to experience the breadth of human expression,
that it is that person named Malia, Alala, or something,
is actually my sister, my daughter, my mother.
It's the same.
They're the same people.
Now in 2002, I went to the restaurants, there was no taste.
Food had no taste, no color,
buildings had no color, nothing.
People would wear just gray.
Because those are luxuries.
But as soon as freedom came, normal as it was,
within two months, you saw color, sound,
music, taste, smell, good smell.
Everything just manifest.
That was such an incredible mental state for me,
to see, "Oh, wow!"
You let a piece of land,
give it some water, vegetation grows.
You leave a piece of land, opportunity for human mind,
and everything grows.
So I say that, life is about management of expectations.
And the worst thing we could have done,
and this is gonna be controversial,
is to create expectation in women.
Because what we lost in these 20,
or what we made in these 20 years,
was the most important thing as human beings
that we can create, which is opportunity for hope,
opportunity for the brain to manifest its full potential.
And we saw that incredibly,
and Ayesha saw that in women that she dealt with.
Right.
I mean, I go in and I thought that I'm talented.
When you bring hungry people, and give them opportunity,
they would blow me away, as far as their talent.
They would learn multiple languages.
One person actually got two degrees within two years.
The women were learning...
I mean, you can speak to that.
Oh my gosh! Yeah.
The level of motivation, that hunger for growth,
for knowledge, for art,
I've never seen that in my life anywhere.
And I think it's because of that contrast,
where there was nothing,
and then suddenly they were given opportunity
that they could do anything they wanted.
And they all chose to be something significant,
not just in their own lives, because they you realized that
in a country where you usually have a group of survivors,
Afghans are mostly survivors.
They've seen governments come and go.
They've seen countries come and go, empires come and go.
And so they have this sense of
self-worth and self-preservation.
But this new generation of women
knew that it has to be beyond that.
It can't just be about the self,
it has to be recreation of stable grounds on which they,
their children and the next generation can live.
So over the past 20 years,
what we've seen is these incredible women
create the infrastructure for themselves
and for the next generation to grow,
and to be someone significant, and to have a voice,
and to propel that voice to the world.
Which makes the removal of that hope
and all of those opportunities,
all the more tragic, of course.
Devastating.
And I think we can debate the pros and cons
of the US withdrawal, and this sense of the occupation
over the last 20 years being an unmitigated boondoggle,
and political disaster, et cetera.
Certainly we can agree that
the withdrawal was bungled on a colossal scale.
But help us understand
the human rights implications of where we are now.
I think it was just one
of the most poorly planned steps ever.
And we could go into the details of that,
but I think in many ways,
it's a disrespect to everyone who's worked there.
It's a disrespect for all the troops
who actually lost their lives there.
I look at it from a very sexist way.
I think it was a very misogynistic step.
I mean, yes, there has been a lot of focus on
translators and allies
who helped the troops do their job and protect them.
But did anybody think about
what was going to happen to the women?
Did anybody ever consider the girls in Afghanistan?
That conversation never comes up.
Did they never see that if Taliban come back,
that they're basically going to ask them
to not exist anymore?
That's exactly what's happening.
Nobody ever thought about women.
They were never part of the plan.
Yeah.
It really wasn't.
And what's interesting about this,
in the context of the advisability of US withdrawing or not,
is the downstream implications of that withdrawal,
and this idea that the occupation
was a bad idea to begin with,
and it was a loser, and it was never gonna...
We were never gonna nation build
to the extent that we aspire to.
And yet there were victories along the way,
and the hope and the opportunities
that were created for these women,
and a big part of your message
is recognizing that some good was done,
which begs the question of whether or not
some form of sustained occupation
could have been advisable in this situation,
to maintain some level of stability
for this type of opportunity.
Absolutely.
I would say that I agree with you,
protracted military existence in Afghanistan
was not a tenable thing.
Not at the numbers that people spoke about.
The small numbers may be, and we have how many...?
We are in over 100 countries right now, just maintaining.
And we were doing well.
How long have we been in South Korea?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, 50 years or more.
Exactly.
So the reason Ayesha brings up
the misogynistic and sexist terms,
is because insouciance has a connotation.
Why would you be indifferent or unaware
or willfully unaware of what has been done in Afghanistan?
Which is not a small matter.
Forget about nation building.
You don't go to nations to build buildings,
you go to nations to build human opportunities.
If that's even an option, but even if it's not,
if it's a by-product, you acknowledge it.
Why is it that building of 16 million women,
to the degree where each of them were incredibly talented,
is not even being acknowledged as a victory.
If nothing else, we did a good job.
The willful insouciance,
the willful ignoring of that fact
says something about us ignoring it.
And then the fact that leaving that vacuum in place,
forget about the vacuum, it's gonna be shrouded, literally.
We talk about Taliban making women wear the burqas,
which covers completely.
Well, it's literally unfair
to lead that across 16 million people,
where that's the death of 16 million people.
Why is that not being talked about?
I don't wanna make this a political thing,
or sexist male, but you have to go to that core.
Why isn't that being addressed?
And that's an important question to ask,
because that question comes to us here in the United States,
that question will come to us in Europe,
that question will come to us everywhere in the world.
If we don't acknowledge the value in the language we use,
we'll live the consequences in the policies we live.
It's funny 'cause when you sent your message to Rich,
that email, then he shared it with me,
when you guys were getting in contact
about coming back on to discuss these issues,
the idea of reframing the 20 years as a triumph,
when everyone was talking about, I think personally,
I think because of the swiftness
with which the Taliban took over,
that that dialogue of failure
has been the main talking point,
I think that has something to do with that.
But the idea of reframing it
as one of the best things the United States taxpayers
have ever done is very interesting.
It's definitely something
I haven't heard anywhere else besides that email,
and now what you're saying today.
And I think that's a really powerful point,
that there was some costs of doing business element,
there was a corruption element,
some money went away that shouldn't have gone,
but maybe that is the cost of doing business
of reclaiming lives that had been erased.
And maybe it is the world's responsibility,
considering Afghanistan is this country
that since the silk road, has dealt with...
Is like has been part of globalization since then, right?
I mean, it's hung in the balance between
whether it's the Soviet and the US in the seventies,
or the British, when they were in Burma in India,
and here's Afghanistan, and trying to figure it out,
and even well before, Alexander The Great,
and the Persian empires.
Afghanistan has been this one place that has been
at the core of so much foreign policy for centuries.
I wonder if you could speak to that,
given your knowledge of the history there, and how...
Take us from that to where we are now, historically,
and why Afghanistan has been so vital.
We're not much of nationalists,
so the borders are not as important as the people.
But in this case, the borders, although they have moved,
it's a unique little real estate.
I wouldn't wanna own land in that real estate,
where your neighbors are, Russia, China, Pakistan, Iran,
and a little further out India.
That's a bad neighborhood.
And you're landlocked.
And not only are you landlocked,
the airplanes where they fly out of Kabul,
they have to use special flight maneuvers,
because it's a bowl with tall mountains.
And everywhere it's like that.
So it's just mountainous land,
beautiful though, absolutely gorgeous.
I remember the first time I went there in 2002,
they took me in a Russian helicopter, and by the way,
I never wanna do that again, because it was an old...
You saw the wires coming out.
They said, "Don't worry, it's gonna be very safe.
Not many people have died from this flight."
And we fly over the mountains, right just barely...
This has Hindu Kush mountains,
which are some of the tallest,
I think the second tallest in the world.
And then we get to this place called Badakhshan,
which is green valleys, little river rats running,
and people are running around.
And I'm like...
I'm crying like a baby, like, "This beauty!"
So it's an incredible land
as far as its extremes, as far as...
And the people are a group of different kinds of peoples
from youngest conquests, to Alexander's conquests.
You see remnants of those features in Afghanistan as well,
as well as some others as well.
So it's a unique population that has been forged in
the crucible of the most difficult space in the planet.
And that's because of the China, Russia, India?
Is that the reason this-?
Pakistan.
The Pakistan, and on top of that, the environment itself,
the mountainous environment...
Like for example, the Panjshir valley just fell,
which is this little space
that had not fallen to the Taliban.
And the reason for that is because external forces, again.
The Russians bombed that place,
Khabarov bombed that place nine times over,
still they couldn't conquer it.
They couldn't conquer the place.
So the geography is just crazy.
When you go there, it's just absolutely...
For nine miles, it takes you four hours
because you have to go these incredible traverse.
So the environment, the landscape,
the neighbors has created these people that are survivors,
caring, loving people that are unique to the region.
But at the same time, it's constant war, constant calamity.
I said, "Please..."
And this again, you've gotta be politically,
I'm known for this.
"Sell the land, buy some space in Florida."
Because it's a tough, tough neighborhood.
It's a tough neighborhood.
But because of that then, the women up to now,
even under Taliban, yeah they shroud them,
very tough women.
These are really resilient people.
I think the withdrawal,
the timing of the withdrawal speaks to the uptick
that we're seeing in Neo isolationism across the world.
So it's not that surprising that it occurred now,
but I think the manner in which we conducted it,
and the mistakes that were made,
and the kind of implications that we're now living with,
really underscores the decline of the United States
as a responsible superpower in so many ways.
I mean, how can any allies trust us again?
How can our friends across the world believe us
when we say we're coming here to do X, Y, and Z,
when we pull out and create the kind of chaos and havoc
that we're now seeing.
And from a boots on the ground perspective,
I wanna know a little bit more about your experience
working there with women,
specifically in these initiatives that you created,
and the legacy of those today, and what's going to happen.
I actually want to highlight
what Adam was referring to earlier.
This is exactly what we saw when we went back,
is a lot of our friends here in the United States
and around the world always refer to
US's existence in Afghanistan as a big failure,
but the positivity and the success that was created
during these last 20 years was probably...
It's something that we all need to talk about and highlight.
And I think it's something
that we all need to be very proud of.
You have a generation of women scientists, doctors,
lawyers, engineers, business women, politicians.
We even have the robotics team,
just incredible human resource.
This is talent that was allowed to flourish.
And these people, not only represented just Afghanistan,
but they represented the best part
of who we are as a human race.
And working with women in Afghanistan,
and seeing them take advantage
of the security was incredible.
And you always compare yourself.
I always compared myself
to some of the women who would work there,
and with the speed of acclimating to change,
and the speed or the hunger that they had
of getting themselves trained in a particular field,
is something I've never seen ever in my life.
And it really shifted the narrative in the society.
And I think one of the reasons
why we saw this massive growth,
where women became leaders,
and you saw change in the society,
was because of the presence of US, and the west there,
that allowed them to flourish and thrive.
And Dean and I were involved
in creating health empowerment programs,
and Dean actually did an amazing job
in the ministry of health, where he created
the most successful health empowerment program,
without ever challenging
the traditions and the cultural norms and the impediments
that were there.
Yeah.
I called it social jujitsu.
I'm terrible with jujitsu, but that's (indistinct).
You're good at social jujitsu.
Which is, you don't confront
longstanding traditions and edicts, right?
It's impossible to challenge.
So you create a pathway there
for the behavior to come forward.
And human behavior will find its path of least resistance,
it will.
So one of the projects...
And by the way, I've said this in the past,
I'm gonna retract that, which is, I created that.
I did not create that.
I led that, or I led it from behind,
because these people did it themselves.
I wanna make sure that we don't...
This leadership thing is overstated.
The environment was created, I kind of created the idea,
but you should see what happens.
So one of that projects was, where we said,
"We're gonna go to these places,
which were Taliban infested."
And they still need healthcare,
because at the time in 2002 average age was 48.
One out of four children were dying before the age of five,
one out of six women were dying during their pregnancy life.
Given that the average pregnant woman
had seven pregnancies, you do the math.
And they didn't just die,
it's the worst death you can imagine,
because they started bleeding,
there's no hospital within four horseback rides.
So they're going to die of severe bleeding and pain,
getting to the hospital by the thousands.
So that was my challenge, coming from NIH,
the richest research institute in the world.
And where for a project for tapping,
we spent like $6 million.
Where here you didn't have penicillin.
So what we did was,
we knew that the lowest denominator of healthcare,
which would save 90% was ORS,
which is Oral Rehydration Fluid, water, salt, and sugar,
because the children that died from diarrhea, dysentery,
and you can't give medicine for that,
you just make sure that the water is retained.
So because of no clean water?
No clean water.
It's like a homemade Gatorade.
Home made Gatorade, yeah.
Yeah , so it's about water sources
and that creates the dysentery that you can't recover from
if you're under five.
Exactly. Exactly.
Women died on the other ones upper respiratory,
one antibiotic ampicillin
would save significant amount of people.
And then women knowing that when they're bleeding
this is spotting as opposed to serious bleeding,
so start now.
And that save thousands.
So who do you need for that?
Do you need doctors? No.
It's useless in Afghanistan.
Do you need hospitals? No.
Although all the people who had money,
wanted to build hospitals, why?
You could show it on TV.
It's all about visibility.
Visibility.
Now, I said,
"Spend it on these young girls,
sixth grade educated young ladies,
who would learn the basics."
So we went to the regions, Taliban leaders,
and we say, "We want to bring healthcare."
They said, "No, no, we don't need it.
We don't need your doctors."
"No, no, no, no. Your own girls."
And they would only see women and children.
"Is that really?
Okay. Okay. Sure."
But I knew what was gonna happen.
We made sure for most part,
the clinics were made in a conspicuous place,
so everybody could see,
because we knew what happens in three months,
guess who gets sick?
The man, the big man.
And he would go to this young girl in a prostrate position,
saying, "Can you help me?"
You just flipped the dynamics.
That woman was now empowered, that woman became a doctor.
Not really, by concept.
And a lot of women ended up in the parliament,
a lot of those women ended up in positions of power.
So you're training medics?
How do you do that.
(crosstalk drowns out the speaker)
You giving them basically EMT training.
Less than EMT.
On the kind of jujitsu tip, how do you accomplish that,
in a Taliban controlled area?
Because any female empowerment,
is a visible threat to the power hierarchy.
Education is a threat,
but healthcare for the women themselves,
their wives, and their daughters, and children is not.
For them to serve each other.
Correct.
Right.
So it was just, "Oh women can go play around it,
and take care of each other."
Well, we knew healthcare is healthcare.
So we actually wrote a paper,
published in peer review journal.
How to empower women in third world countries.
The title was Recalcitrant Countries,
but they changed it, so third world.
So nonetheless that's done, but that wasn't us.
So healthcare just being the vehicle
for empowerment, right?
Yeah.
Because it's a non-threatening, education is threatening.
Ampicillin is not, you're just giving it.
But the bigger picture here was that,
these women took that position,
and took it to the nth power.
Because they became leaders, they became outspoken leaders,
they did more than just healthcare.
And you just created the environment.
And if that's not success, if that's not success,
so either we consider success that,
how much wealth we draw from a country,
or how much wealth human value,
human capital, we leave behind.
The human capital per capita if that's a quantifiable thing,
was exponential in Afghanistan.
From what the base was, to what we left it.
And it's gonna be exponential the other way around now.
Yeah.
Are you in touch with any of these women,
that you helped empower, and what are they telling you now?
Yes, we are.
We've been in touch with a lot of our previous colleagues.
And in this whole chaos,
we've been in touch with good people,
who are trying to evacuate a lot of them.
And there's nothing but sadness, just profound sadness.
And like we said earlier, it's this lack of hope,
and seeing the opportunity of existing fleeing from them,
that is just devastating.
A lot of women are saying that,
if they ever go back to being at home,
and not being able to go back to work or school,
which is exactly what's happened,
the Taliban are telling them that they can't work anymore,
that they can't go to school.
They can't even go out to the grocery store without a man,
a man from their own family.
They accept death.
They said that,
"We would rather die than be in this situation."
A lot of them are rebelling.
They're saying that,
"We're not the same women that we were.
Now we live in the 21st century,
we're highly educated or capable,
and you can't bring this on us."
So in the chaos of fleeing from the country,
and the devastation that the women are already seeing,
those who are left behind,
honestly there's really no hope right now.
Of course, Taliban leadership
is getting behind microphones, and talking about amnesty,
and respecting human rights and women's rights,
but all of this is couched through Sharia law, of course.
So when you run it through that equation,
nothing good is gonna come of this.
Not at all.
And in the nineties, correct me if I'm wrong,
but when the Taliban came to power,
'cause right now they're saying once security gets better,
then you can leave the house,
but we recommend for right now don't.
I mean, women still are leaving the house,
from what I understand in Kabul, at least,
but they're saying, "We recommend you to stay home."
And apparently that's what happened in the nineties.
They never gave a strict order.
They just said, "Right now security is not good,
so you have to stay at home."
And then it gradually got vigilante enforced kind of thing,
in the nineties.
And then that's the concern now,
that it's the same language, actually.
It's not any different.
It sounds to us, we wanna feel,
"Oh, look, they're saying the right things."
But in reality,
that's exactly what they said in the nineties.
Is that correct?
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Exactly.
There's a creep phenomenon, as social creep phenomenon,
where initially they had...
Although this is Taliban 2.0, much better performed,
much better practiced, better language,
but yesterday they killed a journalist,
already there was a women's demonstration,
and they squashed it massively.
Women, they were bleeding on the street
and so on and so forth.
And the other thing is,
you go back to the nature of the thing,
not to get philosophical like the thing in itself,
but the nature of the thing is, around women.
If you think about the laws that they're talking about,
majority of it is women feared, women's centered.
It's kind of funny, isn't it?
An entire system is based on, "How do we shroud women?"
They think women are so powerful,
and it's the sexuality, right?
That the entire...
So women can't go to school or pass the sixth grade.
Now they say past six grade,
but reality is, it's gonna be retracted further.
They can't be in public, and if they are in public,
they have to be completely shrouded.
And so what kind of a system is this?
What benefit is it,
that you're actually hiding a proportion of population?
That nature and the core of that nature,
which is fear of that thing that disturbs you,
and then human beings what is...
We talked about a fair...
Sorry, frail human nature, males ego.
All of us have some of that.
It's so frail there that that nature can't change.
It will collapse back to that fear.
It's so interesting and ironic,
because you have this kind of Taliban archetype,
which is very alpha male but obviously so fragile
that they can't possibly see an unshrouded woman,
and be held to account for their behavior.
So either the male ego is that fragile,
or these women are so all powerful,
that they must be hidden from us,
because we can't be expected to control ourselves.
And well we know what the answer is,
we're writing a behavior book, at the core of human behavior
is sympathetic autonomic system, fight or flight.
If you take out the frontal lobe,
if you take out the basic limbic system,
is that fight or flight, the anxiety component of it,
that raises the heartbeat.
And that component then manifests in anything,
that quickly and rapidly controls it.
Now, complexity is what humanity needs, complexity stuff.
Oh, I have this feeling,
but then all the different variables.
All have it comes back to
slipping back to the basic human nature,
which is, "This is making me nervous."
Although we call it different things,
"and must be bad, therefore it must be eliminated."
Literally that's the core of humanity.
And it can point to this ancient text
that will legitimize and rationalize the worst of behavior.
Yeah.
Or you don't know who translated...
Who knows how that whole thing happened, right?
So, I just want to...
So we're clear,
and I'm sure the listeners know a lot of this,
but I just wanted to elucidate,
what we're talking about when we're talking about misogyny
and at least in Afghanistan.
This is based on a New York Times article
that just published, about how safe houses are closing,
with the Taliban coming through safe houses for women.
Victims of domestic violence are already closing.
Apparently 50% of Afghan women reported physical abuse,
17% sexual violence, 60% in forced marriages.
As opposed to arranged marriages,
these are actually forced marriages.
There's an issue of kidnapping women,
as a way to get back at a family as a dishonorable.
There's honor, killings of your own daughters or sisters
or whatever because of that same idea of,
I guess promiscuity,
or even just a romance outside of an arrangement.
All this is...
Harassment of women in the workplace, that kind of thing.
The Taliban were releasing prisoners
that maybe had been put away for domestic violence.
And then there was worried concern about retribution.
This is all this kind of-
'Cause those prisoners has been released.
Ongoing right now,
and watching the great movie that we both watched,
"How to learn to skateboard in a war zone,
if you're a girl."
Great film about Skater Stan.
I was wondering, 'cause you talked about social jujitsu,
and so some of this stuff though, predates Taliban, right?
Not all of it.
So the Taliban was able to rise,
because some of this was already in the culture.
How can you parse that,
for people who are unfamiliar with Afghanistan?
Why is this an environment
that is tolerant of this behavior?
So education is a big thing.
And the combination of education and opportunity,
opens up the mind.
Lack of education is fear.
I don't mean just academic education, knowledge,
lack thereof creates fear,
and lack of opportunity collapses into
the lowest denominator of interpretation,
especially if you're the only thing you have,
as means of interpreting something, right?
I'm not gonna get into too much of that,
because there'll be a fatwa against me,
but we'll go with that.
Wherever the religion.
It goes back to religion
instead of some other sort of educational background.
Yes, exactly.
So we're talking about...
So the Taliban situation was a little unique.
In the end of 1970s, the Russians came to America,
and we quickly realized, "Oh, we got the trap.
They fell into the trap."
The Russians went to Afghanistan?
The Afghanistan.
Not America.
That's a different movie.
Yeah.
And so during President Reagan's time, they started saying,
"Okay, what can you do to really trap these people?
Create extreme version of interpretation."
So Madrasas were created in Pakistan,
where the most extreme version of Islam,
our interpretation of what was promulgated.
And these young men would be brought in,
and would be just raised under these conditions.
And that interpretation
it's if you die for the cause you go to heaven,
and if you kill for the cause you go to heaven.
Whoa, that's a win-win.
Yeah.
And so thousands and thousands were trained,
and that worked.
In the seventies in Pakistan?
And then the eighties...
And late seventies and the eighties,
that's when the Russians were just demolished,
because you can't defeat a force that doesn't fear death.
Right.
So you have thousands of people
just putting bombs on themselves and putting on the tanks,
and tanks with blow up.
So the Russians were defeated.
But, okay, so you created this incredible force,
incredibly scary force and it's done with.
But some people thought that it was useful still.
We're gonna leave that side aside,
because a lot of people found that useful.
And that scary force was continued.
And now we're seeing that scary force.
The Madrasas continued in Pakistan.
There are continuing to train these young men.
Still today?
Today.
Absolutely.
By the thousands, in fact that's...
And we see the product here
in the United States and Afghanistan,
where they're coming in and they don't know anything.
Most of them are illiterate.
All they know that,
"If I kill, I go to heaven, and if I die I go to heaven."
So the only thing between those two is war,
and that's a scary force.
And oh, by the way, as far as edicts are concerned,
one edict, pray and women should be subjected.
And these are their leaders.
You're not talking about some of the soldiers,
these are their leaders who think that way.
If you look at some of their interviews,
which are not really posted on social media,
or anywhere else for that matter,
but there are some local journalists
who speak to these leaders.
And when you listen to them for a protract amount of time,
where all the filters tend to go away,
and that facade that they put of their peacefulness,
when that goes away,
you see the core true nature of their goals.
And most of them have been raised in these Madrasas,
they've never been exposed to any kind of education.
They've never had internet,
they don't know what the world looks like,
or what exists in the world.
They have no concept of democracy and justice.
And their whole aim is to essentially shroud women,
and implement sharia law, that's it.
And these are the leaders and that's the scariest thing.
And I was looking at an interview, where this man,
he's I think the second person in the leadership right now.
He's probably in his twenties.
And he was talking about women's rights.
Said, "Well, we believe that women should have rights.
Women are our mothers,
they're the representation of the society."
And then suddenly you could see that these statements,
I think he kind of ran out of words
that were told to him to say.
And it just flipped into something like,
"Well, they have to be covered, because that's the rule,
that's the law."
And I was telling Dean, they brought up an example.
So this is the analogy that he used.
He said, "Well, if you go to a farmer's market,
and you see melons, right?
There is a split melon,
and then there's a whole covered melon.
Would you buy the covered melon,
or would you buy the split melon?
The split melon has a lot of germs on it,
and there's a lot of bugs on it.
That's not sweet.
That's not sweet enough for the husband.
The shrouded melon
is the one that you would go and buy one."
So he basically gave an example of how women should be,
by just giving an example of melon.
This is the second highest person in the leadership.
The scariest conversation I've ever heard in my life.
That's how they think.
Despite that, we have this US occupation.
And with that a creep of urban progressive ways of life,
that starts to infiltrate the culture on some level.
But Afghanistan historically being this nation of survivors,
that have defied empires for millennia,
my sense is that most people are going to behave,
in a manner that is survivor expedient for them.
And when you have US troops there,
who can say,
"Well, I don't know how long I'm gonna be here,
but you have to pledge allegiance to us."
And knowing that next week the Taliban is gonna come,
and place the same demands on these people,
people are gonna do what they need to do to survive.
And so it's hard to get a gauge on the temperature...
If you do a temperature check,
on where people's values are, and what they aspire to do,
what they aspire to in their own lives it seems murky
in terms of trying to really understand the culture.
'Cause there is no monoculture.
No, no, no.
It's such an accurate statement in the sense that,
the expression...
Even the people in themselves are in such turmoil right now,
that not only is their language mercurial and capricious
and floating and amoebic, but even their values are that.
And it's not a judgment of them.
It is-
Survival.
It's survival.
I mean, none of us have experienced that.
I mean, what's the worst thing
I experienced in Redondo Beach?
(laughter)
Yeah, sometimes these young people drive really fast across,
in front of my house.
(laughs)
Probably that's the biggest one.
But to know...
When I went there these families said that,
"Right before you guys came during Taliban,
there were rockets being fired every day,
and every family member had a person that had been killed
during the war."
Every single family member killed.
We don't have any idea of that.
So you're right, it's survival now.
And it's at the pace of the vacuum,
and the vacuum is the thing, right?
The vacuum that's left behind.
So we've started this organization called
Restore Her Hope, and the-
Restore Her Voice.
Her Voice.
I keep coming back to hope.
Cause you're looking for hope.
I'm looking for hope,
Restore Her Voice, because we said, "Where can we help?
Where can we help?"
Not just in Afghanistan,
because we're women's rights and justice and all that.
And it's gonna be broader.
It's not going to be us going there and saving people.
My goodness, I couldn't even do some pushups, as you heard.
I'm not a warrior, I'm a scientist.
What's the most effective...
And this is important.
What's the most effective unit of a society.
And we have three men here and...
Well, four, and one woman here,
the most effective unit of productivity
in a society are the women,
a dollar spent in healthcare and on women,
is at the minimum four times more effective
than anything else.
And the same is true across all spectrums.
And when you give women voice,
especially if they've been empowered already,
that becomes the most powerful force in the society,
positive force.
And in United States or other places,
when you take women's rights away,
when you take their voices away,
it becomes the nightest of the most destructive cycle.
In fact, I think that's the beginning of a fall.
So that's why we thought that,
giving women their voices back,
both Afghan or otherwise especially post-traumatic,
is I think the most effective thing we could do.
So what do you do?
What's the organization do like specifically?
Our goal is to highlight and promote women,
who have lived in Afghanistan,
who have been through the trauma for them to be the voice,
and for them to be the platform
for all women living in Afghanistan,
and in any other country.
I think the stories that they tell,
the kind of perspective that they give us is invaluable,
because it really touches the true core
of who we are as a society, and as human beings.
And we want to provide them
not necessarily just the same platform they had,
all these brave and courageous women
who've fled the country,
the same platform here in the United States,
but to help them get to the right people,
the right groups, the right organizations,
to be able to promote this message,
that women's rights is human rights.
And they need to be at the same seat,
if not at a higher seat of making decisions for themselves,
and for this world.
We have incredible politicians,
YouTubers, artists, scientists,
who have been forced out of the country.
And so we're trying to welcome them.
We're trying to give them some stable ground,
and let them speak for the country.
So it's the platform for these various women
of different backgrounds?
Yeah, absolutely.
Right.
Like this diaspora of women.
Where are some of these women who have gotten out,
where are they settling,
or are they just spread out all over the place?
What is the kind of refugee landscape look like?
They've been spread out.
Yeah, it's a little chaotic right now.
The women we were talking about,
and we've identified a few of them are in Washington DC.
And some of them are actually in Los Angeles area as well.
What happened was a huge number of people
were brought out to Qatar and other places, Germany.
And then from there to US, and other places.
And in US, they're kept in big spaces in Washington
and Dallas and other places.
But the women that we are talking about,
they were leaders of their fields.
For example, there's a woman
that was the head of the Orchestra,
and actually played in Kennedy Center, right?
So she's in the United States.
We're hoping to give her the platform,
to not just get to where she was before,
but also speak about that.
I really think the most important thing as human beings
we can do, is speak.
Speak fearlessly, speak often, speak with errors,
make mistakes, but speak, speak, speak,
and speak the truth without any abatement,
nobody's telling us not say certain things.
And out of that, that's a pair of phenomenon of evolution,
that sped up revolution billion times,
our ability to speak fearlessly.
And if these women who have the power,
who have the tools, who've lived those experiences,
I think there will be a megaphone for the cause.
And it also highlights how similar we are.
And when we speak,
we realized that all those artificial differences,
whether it's language, or the way we dress,
or the way we speak, or we carry ourselves it just false.
One of the things that we are trying to do,
is to make every American living here in the United States
and around the world,
for them to feel that these women are them.
They are you, they're the neighbor that you have,
they're your mom, they're like your sister.
They're like your daughter.
They're like your friend.
They're no different.
And if we can shorten the distance
between those differences,
and engage in conversations with them.
I think we can all work towards a better world.
We can be better versions of ourselves.
Adam mentioned the short documentary
"Learning to Skateboard."
What's it called?
In a war torn.
In a War Zone.
If you're a girl.
Which I believe won the Oscar, in 2019.
(crosstalk drowns out the speaker)
I watched it this morning and I was literally weeping,
because to watch that movie now,
in the context of what's transpired
over the last couple of weeks.
It's so heart wrenching and you can't help but think,
"Where are these young women now?
And what are they doing?
And is there any possibility or hope,
for getting people out of the country at this point?"
We all bore witness to what transpired at the airport.
But with the Taliban stranglehold
on the country at the moment,
there doesn't seem to be an opportunity.
Unfortunately not.
We're seeing this diminishing of the efforts at this point.
And trying not to lose hope,
and it's difficult not to lose hope
at this point, to be honest.
To make it my field, our field, neurology.
So we're a big signal detecting device, right?
Our brain.
We don't get out of our comfort,
unless something happens, that gets out of comfort, right?
And for millions of years,
that was because we had the distinguish
between a bush and a lion.
Now it's a little more complex,
human behavior, social aspects.
I think these are opportunities,
and I don't wanna make it sound...
Diminish what we just talked about,
16 million people dying basically.
And we should address that,
I think is an opportunity for us
to have more complex conversations,
about humanity in general, women and women's rights,
and what we consider success.
Again, we repeat what we did in Afghanistan,
incidentally, maybe as a pair of phenomenon, maybe.
It doesn't matter,
the consequence was the most successful thing
we've ever done.
If we consider success, the degree of change or Delta,
as they say in science.
The Delta of it, the Delta was just absolutely bewildered.
And if that's not success,
then your value system is based on an antiquated system.
You better reassess your values,
even though you're wearing the nice clothes,
and the tie and everything,
you're in the wrong place psychologically.
We did succeed, and then we failed it,
because we didn't know that this was success.
And why didn't we know that?
And it's not about Afghanistan.
We believe in throughout the world.
We've traveled 50 countries or more.
And I think if we reframe the situation to speak about that,
that our success is just this,
women's rights which will create connectivity,
and women's leadership, feminine leadership,
which is more of....
We talk about leadership and my background,
leadership is all feminine.
The part that's masculine, which is the muscle,
it's just a couple of people, but it's feminine.
And it's about conversation, communication, connecting.
And if we increased that Quanta in the world,
the world will be a better place.
If we reframe our successes around that concept,
we will be a better society.
We will not let that destructive seed
regrow in our own country.
And it will regrow now in our country.
Well, we're seeing aspects of that now.
I'll let you do it.
With what's going on in Texas at the moment.
But yeah, I think that it's a very good point,
in that we don't identify the successes in Afghanistan,
because that is not our priority.
We define success by whether or not
we could create a thriving democracy,
and a stable police force,
and military that could protect the border,
and instilled democratic values across the country.
We failed at that.
There's this other huge success here,
but because of our sort of cultural priorities,
we don't consider that a success.
Yeah, I think you brought it back to nationalism.
America has had nationalism like pledge of allegiance,
the Star-Spangled Banner for the ball games,
the American flag you see everywhere.
I'm not denigrating any of that,
it's just a part of the culture.
So when that's a part of the culture,
and then you see servicemen dying over there,
and it seems far away.
Like, what you're suggesting is a complete paradigm shift,
in global culture, (crosstalk drowns out the speaker)
which is worth aspiring to,
but it's just not, unfortunately,
it's just not the majority of the people thinking that way.
We should think that way we should.
But globalism has gotten a bad name,
'cause it's always thought in economic terms.
This is also is benefit economically, when you can lift...
Like you said, and lift the women up economically,
it lifts the entire country up economically.
But I think that not to say it shouldn't happen,
it's just probably the explanation
for why it's not happening.
There's a concept of American imperative, which was...
There's a little bit of a scary side of it in the 1800s.
And almost like as if it was meant,
that we should conquer and all that.
But let's flip that, this jujitsu.
Let's do too little jujitsu there,
what if the American imperative,
is a new kind of empire that prospers that grows,
but also changes societies for the...
We keep using the word democracy as if it's a thing.
There are different ways of that democracy.
And in fact, in Afghan was pretty...
We had more women at one point
in the parliament in Afghanistan,
than we did in US Congress.
Because by law,
it was in the doctrine that they had to have 33%,
or one third women.
So they were active, they were outspoken.
They would tell...
I actually have seen one of them women actually
turn to a very, very powerful warlord,
and then shut him down.
So that was a great success.
So not to kind of get too much into that,
but the success that we had in Afghanistan,
is I think should be addressed.
And I think one of the first places that we've seen,
is here we're doing it,
because I think it's great learning for all of us,
as a society, as a nation, as a great nation,
as a new empire, if you don't like the word empire,
a great nation, large nation,
who can do great things but at the human level.
And it was done, and was lost.
Yeah. Yeah.
We don't seem to value that kind of soft analysis though.
It's really those kind of tactile benchmarks
that we're judging our progress by.
And in the meantime I think we've lost our footing,
as a nation that was known
to take the moral high ground in situations like this,
but I'm interested.
And you guys are neurologists,
and you think a lot about the brain.
How do we...
Help us understand, the mind of the Taliban.
What is going on neurologically with such an individual,
that they hold a worldview that they do,
and conduct themselves in a manner
that seems so retrograde and foreign to Westerners.
I'm gonna take it and then you'll take it from there.
We could talk for days about this one.
It's actually easier than people think,
if anybody has a teenage son who has sex...
Well, that's a redundant sexual urge...
Teenage son had sexually...
That's a redundant thing.
But so it's a teenage son that doesn't know much,
not very educated, and its entire world purview
is condensed to one little set of values,
that it's learned repeatedly over and over again.
And then it's told that
it should actually control all urges.
That's the Taliban. That's it.
The core neurology of that is base human instincts,
and a set of edicts to control those base human-
Well, in the effort to control those urges and instincts,
there's gonna be some errands sideways behavior.
Yeah. Yeah.
The women are the scariest thing to them, right?
The women are the things that...
I remember going to Afghanistan,
and talking to some of these back Taliban,
and it would be interesting,
that every other conversation would be about some edict
around women issues,
because it's the emotion that disturb them the most.
So there's emotion that must be subdued the most.
That's very simple human...
Humanity is less complex than we think we are.
It starts with those core parasympathetic
and parasympathetic systems,
that goes to the limbic emotional brain,
that interprets things in the most survival based way,
which means more of a control, more control,
eliminate any possibility of danger
by reducing the number of variables, which means...
And that's basically the human nature
when it's not allowed to flourish.
And everything starts from a fears stance.
So everything is based on fear,
fear of the other, fear of the different,
fear of something that will take away things from you.
I think people start becoming more nuanced,
when the fear goes away.
Yes, that could be a luxury, if you're secure,
if you're not hungry, if you're not under attack,
you probably don't have enough fear
and you can explore things.
But if you exist in a fearful environment, which they have.
They've been told as children that,
"Someone will kill you, someone will attack you.
The other person who doesn't look like you is different.
So you have to stay away from that."
And the fear of women, the fear of your urges,
your base urges, everything is based on that.
And that's why sticking to a set of rules and regulations,
in coming back to that over and over again, as a reflex.
And that fear is solidified over many, many years,
so much that it's impossible for anything outside
to be introduced.
That's why I think it's...
Some people say that they may be open to conversations,
or they may be open to change, they won't.
There's no hope for that.
This comes down...
There are parallels to the United States,
if you're not able to have a sexual release,
there will be violence.
If you can't get laid, you will kill.
And we have involuntary celibate men here,
who bring the guns and shoot people at schools,
or in on the streets.
And that happens here.
In Texas we have a set of laws are making it harder to vote,
and are controlling women's bodies without their consent.
That's happening here.
It's like those dominoes are here.
So that's an extreme case of something that is,
I guess, universal, but it's happening here
probably more than a lot of places as well.
So I find that interesting.
I think there's also an economic element to this, right?
I was just doing some research, and looking at the ISIS-K,
and how that started in Afghanistan in 2015.
And they were paying people $700 a month, to come join ISIS.
And that's a lot of money,
and it's not that dissimilar to stuff
I've seen in cartel countries and Nicaragua and Mexico,
where all of a sudden ISIS like these cartels,
are paying for the healthcare
and paying for education.
They make sure that
the payroll is met,
whereas the American forces the checks are bouncing,
and you couldn't count on that.
And I assume the Taliban are paying for fighters too.
So there is an economic element of it, right?
And there is that,
people are going to where the paycheck is.
There are two elements to that.
You're absolutely right.
So again there's a measure of support
for these people, right?
Where's that coming from?
Yeah.
So the measure of support is coming from...
It's a carrot and stick kind of thing.
The element that they were...
There's a huge percentage of population,
who are not happy with the government as it was,
because there was corruption.
And corruption came in Afghanistan
because a country that was hungry had nothing,
all of a sudden, you brought in warlords
to run the government.
And I know that's a controversial, but it is true,
I mean, they know themselves.
And some of them were good, some of them were not,
but there was a lot of corruption.
We're talking in the billions.
We know that the Central Bank of Afghanistan $900 million,
was just usurped and taken away.
And they found who it was.
They didn't do anything about it,
because the president's brother was involved in it.
So they didn't do anything.
And then the commanders were involved,
so they didn't do anything.
So with people were getting frustrated,
their life is not getting better,
but other people in the community, or society are getting.
So a lot of frustration with corruption, that's one element.
So my life is not gonna change too much yet,
for them men especially.
For the men, life is not gonna change too much.
If I was poor, I'm gonna be poor.
Now you have a force that's dark.
It's not gonna affect me,
maybe my wife, maybe that's good for me, and my daughter,
but at least they're going to control corruption.
And they did.
The other element is, money that's coming from the Taliban
is from outside countries.
And from poppy number one source of opium and all that,
is Afghanistan.
They have that system better regulated,
than the government had their systems regulated.
And like you said, people were getting paid on time,
as opposed to the government.
So both of those issues are economic,
you're absolutely right.
And then economy has a big, big factor.
And the answer to all your questions is money, right?
In a way, yeah.
Money and education.
And money...
Hoping that education gets people's fears away.
But that's not always guaranteed.
But there's also this asymmetry,
when you have religious fundamentalists,
zealots who are fighting a religious war,
versus western troops who are there
because they've been deployed there,
and are trying to win hearts and minds
in a situation that is at best an extremely uphill battle.
So it's lined up for a loss right out of the gate.
It seems like it was from the beginning.
The thing to do would've been to chase the Taliban
into Pakistan and they just couldn't do it,
because of borders and politics.
Or they just were unwilling to do it,
until Obama finally said, "We're gonna get Osama Bin Laden,
but that allowed a safe haven, right?
For them to regain and get financing.
And then there's also Iran has what?
According to this frontline report I saw today,
five to 10,000 people in Afghanistan are aligned with Iran,
and this quest to maybe create
a (indistinct) type situation,
if the Taliban fails quickly.
I mean, we're looking at a possible civil war-
Not a possible, it's going to happen.
And it's gonna get radical,
because when you create a vacuum,
and there are elements of vacuum
where different crystals can manifest, they will manifest.
They will manifest.
And they will be radical manifestation, because of anger,
lack of economy and lack of education.
And I think people in power know this.
Well, not to make it too political, throughout history,
Afghani's instability has been used
as a weapon for the neighbor's stability.
Mm-Hmm.
So that's going to happen.
Mm-Hmm
Meanwhile, all of these accomplished women
are redonning the burkas,
inscasing themselves in their homes, not going outdoors.
It's a return to a Stone Age existence.
Completely so.
It already has.
And that is the saddest thing that we're seeing right now.
And I tell you,
I don't see them being defeated back anyway at this point,
because of the partnerships of the neighbors.
Like China already moved in with some deals,
I think, because Afghanistan, there's a lot of resources.
They say up to $3 trillion in minerals,
not just lithium, but across the board,
even uranium and everything else.
So China's moving in, and Pakistan, Iran,
and then our calmest neighbor right now.
That's the calmest neighbor, Russia.
Imagine that's your calmest neighbor.
Yeah.
It's Crazy, isn't it?
Your calmest neighbor is Putin.
Putin, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's just taking it easy right now.
Yeah.
Rich, can I shout out some of these names
that we had bolded here, some accomplished women,
just maybe I'll just read them off,
and some of their accomplishments,
and you guys have some thoughts about them, that'd be good.
Shukria Barakzai.
She was mentioned in this great article that you sent over,
that Lindsay Adario wrote,
who is currently shooting wildfires in Tahoe.
(laughs)
Incredible photojournalist, as we all know.
She went from getting beaten in the street by the Taliban
during the nineties to once the Taliban were gone,
helping to draft the constitution
and serve two terms in parliament.
Do you-
I worked with her.
I knew her.
I actually was in many conversations with her.
Amazing human being.
Just powerhouse of a human being.
Yeah.
Is she still there?
She is. Yeah. Yeah.
Fawzia Koofi.
Yeah.
Fawzia Koofi, porter her life in the country
since the Taliban came to power in 96,
she started a network of secret girls schools
in the nineties in her home province called Badakhshan.
Is that right?
And a member of parliament from 2005, 2019,
and was one of the people representing Afghanistan,
the Republic in peace negotiations with the Taliban,
and is now...
Finds herself out of the country,
and trying to figure out it's next. Correct?
Powerful woman, outspoken.
She still is.
She actually is one of the most outspoken Afghan women
on Twitter.
And she recently...
She didn't want to get out.
She actually promised
that she was going to stay back and fight,
but when they threatened her,
because these Taliban go from home to home,
looking for these strong powerful women
and who were part of the government,
and so she had to flee with two daughters in Qatar,
but she vowed to be connected and as loud as she can.
Yeah.
Her daughters got out in advance of her, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Mahbouba Seraj, who I hadn't heard of, who is-
One of our favorite people.
I saw her in on the CNN.
I think, was...
Some clip, and it was...
She's one of the Afghan women's network, she's staying.
She says, "I'm going outside no matter what."
(laughs)
And is hoping to work together, right?
She's saying that in good faith,
hoping to try to figure out a way to run the country
in a positive direction.
She's always been an ultimate optimist.
An outspoken woman, absolutely love her.
I hope she's safe.
And Pashtana Durrani, a young woman, she's 23 years old,
executive director of an organization called Learn.
She's in hiding right now.
Trying to organize girls schools on the digital platform.
Pashtana is a great example
of what happens when there's opportunity.
She's in her twenties,
so she is the latest generation of Afghan women
who had the opportunity to educate herself and help others.
And she's done a phenomenal job.
But she's in grave danger, because they've threatened her.
She's created multiple schools,
she actually has a very strong social media presence.
And she's actively speaking against the Taliban right now.
What is the social media situation in Afghanistan?
Do they have Twitter and people tweet,
and like what happens with somebody
who says the wrong thing.
It's ending.
There are YouTubers,
who have completely stopped posting their videos.
There's this one a very popular show,
a bowling show of a young lady
who is now in the United States.
She used to invite politicians
and people in the position of power to come bowl.
And during that bowling session,
she would actually challenge their politics and their-
That's a great idea.
(laughs)
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
That's a great YouTube show.
It's like hot ones.
Yeah.
Then there's this guy Rusto Moja on Instagram,
who's been doing some
really interesting reporting young guy.
And one of the things that we're hearing from the Taliban,
is like,
"Oh, yes, we're going to ensure an open media ecosystem."
But he shared a video clip of a television news host,
with two...
He's in a tie and he's reporting the news,
and there's two Talibans
standing behind him with their rifles.
That was supposed to be a debate by the way.
Right.
Yeah.
That's gonna be great debate with two (indistinct).
I like that.
That's the old world debate.
That's right.
What do you think about that?
Yeah. Whatever you think.
(laughs)
Rusto is only 19, he's one of the youngest activist.
Where does he...
He's British, Afghan.
I believe he's in the UK.
Yes.
And he's been posting clips that are filmed by individuals,
and journalists in Afghanistan.
So things that are not really posted
out in the media, that often.
I am in love with this young woman,
Shamsia Hassani the first
Afghan female graffiti street artist.
Her Instagram is incredible.
The stuff that she is done.
But she's still there, I think.
Yeah.
But she's kind of gone underground, it appears.
A lot of them have.
We have put together a list of articles,
and a list of these Instagram accounts.
And in addition documentaries,
like the one we mentioned before,
and plenty of other books and resources,
that will put in the show notes
for people that wanna dive deeper,
into everything that we've been talking about today.
There was like the Tom Morello story,
that you liked right there.
Oh yeah. I like that one.
Guitars Rage Against the Machine's
was promoting this guitar school.
That was also kind of like Skateboard Stan.
But with music a place for girls to get educated,
as well as learn guitar,
and a rock producer had relocated to Kabul,
and started to teach guitar, just one girl at a time,
and it created this whole thing.
And before I just wanted to ask one last question,
'cause we skated over this,
and you had said at the opening, Ayesha, that...
And I've spent time on Mesa, Thailand,
and a lot of time in Burma,
and so I understand where...
I haven't been in active war zone
quite like that, but there was still...
It displaced people and mine fields and that kind of stuff,
not too far away.
And I spent some time in there,
but what was interesting was
two parallels, one is medics,
training villagers as medics was a key towards development.
And the other thing was
this landscape of international people,
coming from all over the world, aid money,
and network of people all there for what purpose,
and that's to help people, and then romance,
and you guys met in that kind of a scenario.
What was it like in those heady day,
in those early 2002, 2003, 2004.
It's like, who's there, where are you going after dinner?
Like all that kind of stuff.
Oh Gosh.
I'll give my version, then you can give your version.
Okay.
My version is better.
No, no, no.
So as I said,
we both came from completely different environments,
America, modern, I was doing-
But you have this
great rich family history with Afghanistan.
We do.
I mean, my grandfather was the reformed king,
that was actually thrown out in 1920s.
His secretary of education was my grandfather.
So our pride and joys,
the fact that he was the secretary of education,
that brought women's reform,
that brought education into the country.
And my grandfather was friends with her grandfather,
who came back to United States.
Yeah. They were very good friends.
It's like a movie.
Yeah, yeah.
They came back to United States.
He came back to United States, went to John's Hopkins...
Sorry, Columbia University Medical School Surgery,
and then went to Hopkins is to become public health expert,
went back to Afghanistan, and created the...
Sorry, I'm not gonna-
No, no.
A parliament, a part of constitution.
Brilliant, brilliant man.
And then my grandfather, same thing.
And of course, when you do good things there,
my grandfather was kicked out early.
So his sons came to United States in the fifties.
They are doctors here, surgeons.
We stayed, my parents stayed.
In the 1970s, the communist came,
and immediately everybody ran to America,
and we were not very smart, we went to Pittsburgh,
but no offense to Pittsburgh.
I love Pittsburgh, it's my home.
But we grew up there.
But when was involved in the community,
not as much as I thought, but public health, yes.
I was asked to go back to Afghanistan to help reconstruct.
And at the time I was, I was at NIH.
They said just three months hiatus,
went back became three years.
But in the first year in a party, expat party,
expats are these internationals that come together.
And the party's there, because you're in a war zone,
it's horrible situation.
Everything is abated, alcohol, everything,
everybody's just drinking.
And I'm sitting, talking to some people,
and she pulls a chair next to me.
That's my version.
And she sits next to me, and we start talking.
And the first time conversations about our grandparents.
And they both had Alzheimer's,
and they both died of Alzheimer's in dementia.
Crazy, the (crosstalk drowns out speaker).
And then we start talking and talking.
And then because I was at the time the deputy minister,
I had this white car, with driver and security.
I offered to drive them to their hotel,
and I drive her to her hotel with her mom.
And then we lose each other.
And I chased them.
That's a whole thing.
I found her,
and then we dated in Afghanistan with our bodyguard.
I gotta say this part.
Oh, that is it.
The ministry of interior had given us a bodyguard,
because I was threatening people but just my beliefs.
And the bodyguard was WAT,
fully dressed, 80 pounds, 90 pounds at most.
And he had this liniest...
(laughs)
You know how soldiers have this bullets here?
He had a line of marijuana or hashish
roll up here, right there.
I'm like, "You're a police officer.
You're a cop."
But he actually was a teacher.
He was a teacher from Badakhshan.
And we used to call him (speaking in foreign language)
which means dear teacher.
And he was forced to work in the army as a bodyguard,
because he couldn't make enough money.
So he was our chaperone.
And when we would go to a hotels or to restaurants,
to have dinner, he would actually follow us.
He would fall asleep all the time.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
Bodyguard with the kind (indistinct).
There were times when Dean had to carry
(indistinct) to the car.
Let's go, it's time to go home.
And he would wake up.
And just-
So that's how we met.
Although, he was a beautiful poet too.
Here's the thing, I don't know how you guys,
as neurologists feel about free will,
whether humans have free will or don't have free will,
but this all feels very predestined to me.
It does.
The work that you're doing now
and everything that you've done.
When you look back
through the generations of your family histories.
I consider myself very lucky.
And I think there's a lot of work to do.
Us being neurologists,
and talking about flex and tangles in Alzheimer's disease,
and being involved in all the science,
and putting a halt to that not necessarily a halt,
but refocusing on what is making us strong as human beings.
That's one of the reasons,
and I think that's a continuation of the stories
of our grandfathers and all these amazing human beings,
especially women that we met in Afghanistan.
The work we do even now,
it's not the esoteric clinical trials and stuff.
We are, I think the only neurologists,
that work in the communities.
That's right.
We lead one of the largest brain health initiatives
in the world.
With the focus on women.
They're centered on women.
So, meaning that
we actually take the women in the community.
We train them,
'cause we know that they're going to have the most impact,
and coming back to that.
And they're the most successful by far.
As far as destiny, well, it depends on the searching mind,
doesn't it?
If you're search, you meet your destiny.
If you're not searching, you meet your destiny.
You dodge the free will question without though.
(laughter)
I'm a little bit of
on Harris' school of thought on free will.
Can I ask a question about the neurology?
'Cause you talked about the resiliency
of so many of these women,
and especially the women who are given freedom,
and look what they can do.
I wonder as neurologists,
if you saw also some of the fallout on the other side,
where this kind of being forced to shroud stay inside,
does that contribute to early onset dementia?
Do you see some of these neurological issues,
that present earlier, maybe through this environment,
or does the survivor in you take precedence,
and eliminate that?
That's a good question.
I don't think we have hard data on that.
The one thing that is quite evident is this prevalence,
massive prevalence of anxiety and depression.
And it's not the typical anxiety and depression,
because sometimes when you're in survivor mode,
you don't really have the time
to show the manifestation of depression.
So when you are always wondering,
what your children are going to eat the next day,
and when you're always wondering,
whether you're going to have a shelter tomorrow or not,
or whether your loved one
is going to be around your dinner table or not,
there's no time for you to sit back and feel bad.
There's this massive amount of anxiety
that people live with.
Yes, there are a lot of deaths,
because of cardiovascular disease,
and the other manifestations of stress and anxiety.
I don't think anybody has actually done work,
to look at the neurological manifestations of that.
And especially in the last 20 years with early deaths,
and people dying of easily preventable diseases.
They probably don't even get to that point,
where the neurodegeneration aspect
actually starts kicking in.
Just as a continuation of that.
I mean, that's a beautiful answer.
So I shouldn't, but I'll just give it a little bit.
So the human brain,
we're here outside of the intangible answers,
that why we're here,
the tangible is we're here because of the...
As much valued as we have for it's our brain, right?
Especially our feeling brain.
Dekar said (speaking in foreign language).
I say, (speaking in foreign language)
I feel therefore I am.
As much as we can feel, as much...
That's why the animal thing, that's why...
If you don't distill the cause to the base value,
which is ability to feel, it's meaningless.
So as far as feeling is concerned, yes that's the brain.
The brain is here to feel, but at the same time,
it's also here to explore.
Feel fully, and there are levels of it, and explore fully.
When the brain is not...
And this, we don't have data in Afghanistan,
but outside of Afghanistan,
when a brain is not exploring, it shrinks.
The moment the brain stops exploring,
and exploring could be anything thinking, reading,
playing music,
all of this stuff except for playing Sudoku, which I hate,
but all these manifestations of creativity,
of the mind being coming to the fore.
And if it's not doing that, it shrinks.
It has more consequence than eating bad.
And I'm a nutritionist.
I have a master's in nutrition, she has a master...
Inability to let the brain be creative, destroys the brain.
And we have entire 50% of the general population shrouding,
not being able to think.
You're killing them.
Yeah.
And that's true in America.
It's true everywhere.
So as far as why we're here is let people's creativity roam,
let it flourish.
Don't be scared.
We have latitude.
I hope that this conversation is not...
People recognize not for Afghanistan only.
America we have to be fearless,
and out of the creativity each individuals will,
to manifest their full potential.
Stop shrouding it.
Yeah.
And I think the solutions to these problems,
be they in America, Afghanistan, or elsewhere,
certainly there are other conflict zones across the world,
and genocides and plenty of problem.
But finding our way forward begins with empathy,
and empathy is about understanding.
And I appreciate you guys coming here today,
to help us understand better,
so that we can breed the empathy
that's required to manifest the solutions.
But before we kind of end this
I do wanna spend a few moments
just talking about the solution,
you've got this organization Restore Her Voice.
I know there's a GoFundMe component to that.
So if people are listening or watching,
and they feel the urge
or the call to contribute in a meaningful way,
like what is the best outlet for time and resources?
I'm grateful to you for allowing us to use your platform,
to spread this message?
I think one of the best things that people can help with is,
to be the voice of these women,
who have been silenced by the dark antiquated,
and ignorant forces in Afghanistan.
And for us to help rebuild the same kind of situation,
that they had in the past 20 years for them to speak up.
I think these women
coming from Afghanistan to the United States,
are the best representatives of the harsh environment there,
and of the beautiful potential that women have there.
And so if they want to help us,
we would be grateful to them.
We've already raised a whole lot,
with the help of these kind amazing individuals,
more than a hundred thousand dollars,
over the last couple weeks.
And we're going to use all of these resources,
to help these women establish themselves,
and reach their potential,
and be a representation of the women in Afghanistan.
And people can go to the website restore,
what is it, Restore Her Voice.
Restorehervoice.org.
.org.
That's the website.
And we are on social media as well, Restore Her Voice.
What's say you, Adam Skolnick?
I'm just grateful to be a part of this conversation,
and to met you both,
and you Rich for scheduling it so I could be here.
And it's just this is kind of stuff,
that makes you wanna be a journalist,
and be a writer is to explore these stories,
and try to contribute in some small way to a huge problem.
And so I appreciate being a part of it.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I think that we mentioned Skate to Stan earlier,
but we didn't really explain it.
So if these issues are brand new to you, listener, viewer,
maybe start with that documentary,
'cause it's a really beautiful portrait,
of an effort at grass roots level,
to empower young girls in a very heartwarming way,
by creating this school
that is behind tall walls and hidden,
wherein they teach young girls how to skateboard.
They've got a skate ramp,
but they use it also as a platform for empowerment,
by teaching them the soft skills,
so that they can value themselves.
And it's really quite beautiful,
and it's like 40 minutes long or something like that.
Yes, it's a beautiful, beautiful documentary.
And then I found electric literature is a good website,
in the literary world and Nadia Hashimi
a writer who's in the Afghan diaspora.
She put together a list of books, by or about Afghan women.
So I think you're gonna link to that as well.
Correct?
Oh, Right.
Eight books by and about Afghan women.
Right.
So we'll put that in the show notes.
Amazing.
Yeah. Cool.
So people can kind of get into that and...
Like that documentary of the 1950s in Afghanistan,
and to see how it was trending,
and where it is now,
it just shows you how fragile it really is.
Yeah, yeah.
That's exactly right.
I mean, it was so progressive.
It had developed so much,
that nobody would've envisioned that it would collapse.
Not only did it collapse, it collapsed twice.
Progress is fragile.
And I think it's an important reminder,
that we not take for granted our liberties and our freedom,
and to be more vigilant about what is right and correct,
and fair and equitable.
But also like not to have such hard...
Like I think when you get to a point
where there's such hard polarization and hard boundaries
between left and right or up whatever it is, red and blue,
you actually are contributing to a potential of a fall.
Whereas if there's much, much more free flow
of ideas and receptivity, I think you have a better chance.
If there's hard walls and obstacles between,
that's gonna impede intellectual growth, I think.
But that's what we're seeing right now
in the United States, a calcification of ideologies,
that's making conversation and communication
more and more difficult,
and that is exacerbating the polarization,
and I think the problem
that we're contending with right now.
And the result is something like in Texas,
that should have been nipped in the bud,
with better organizing and communication, right?
Like you think, right?
So that, yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much, Rich.
How do you feel?
Feel good?
Feels amazing.
Did we do it?
Oh my gosh!
Absolutely, I love you guys so much.
Thank you.
This is not full and flattery I'm an honorary guy.
You're doing the most important thing.
Having courageous conversations.
Trying to do it.
It is absolutely.
And these guys
have this idea this concept
of the last 20 years in Afghanistan,
that just completely flips it on its head.
And it seems so obvious to reading that email.
Wow! This was a success.
But before that, it wasn't even in my mind.
And so I think it's brilliant,
to have this kind of counterintuitive notion put out there,
I think is super important.
I think we should all take pride in that.
And unfortunately that's not the narrative,
that you see every day.
So thank you for this opportunity
to actually talk about that.
Thank you.
And thank you for the wonderful gift.
This book, this Steve McCurry book,
which is quite a work of art.
It really is.
Appreciate it.
It really is, of course.
It will hold a proud spot here in the studio.
So thanks and you guys are welcome here anytime.
Thank you, Rich.
Appreciate it.
You are always so kind. Thank you.
It was so nice meeting you all.
Thank you.
How was they?
(laughter)
(contemporary upbeat music)